one of the cofounders of merging vets
and players with bright back here on the
show
Nate Boyer good to see you sir good to
see you you got it you you you've you've
brought us up quite a bit man don't act
like this is the first time no no no no
I know that but I just you know I never
know who's just tuning in you know
people don't listen every day religious
you know what the whole three hours I
should agree with you that they probably
do I won't even try to do but it was so
moving to me and again let's just there
might be people who are surfing in for
the first time
explain what what MVP merging veteran
players is em MVP is basically an
organization veteran service
organization that doesn't just serve
veterans it serves former professional
athletes as well and we bring these two
groups together and help them find
purpose and service and community and
you know that locker hood Brotherhood
camaraderie Locker hood locker room yes
all those things that that we really
miss when that uniform comes off you
know obviously we would never and will
never compare what we do on the
battlefield and versus the playing field
or anything like that but that
transition afterwards
typically you're in your 20s and 30s and
that identity is gone you know the
career is over and you feel often very
disconnected from from the group from
the team that you had you were part of a
part of a mission you know you you had a
specific role and people relied on you
and you know if you're played for an
athlete playing on that big stage and
identifying with you know the what do
you call it the maize and blue yes sir
or or whatever it is right you know
that's just it becomes a part of who you
are and then you just feel like I I
don't know I'm not part of the packet
anymore part of the tribe and a lot of a
lot of guys will isolate and sort of run
from that pass you know what I mean
instead of sort of embracing it and then
using it moving forward and so we just
we lift each other up we we work out
together every Wednesday night
then we talk about our stuff we sit
around and huddle and you know you got
to experience it yourself yes
I mean Shawne Merriman is was one of the
former players that were there and you
too you got to experience both sides of
these things obviously you did most of
your long snapping at Texas where you
would go back and forth between the
campus at Austin and playing football
games for the University of Texas and
then go and have three different combat
tours in Iraq and Afghanistan
so you're the perfect person that's the
perfect glaze I'm the perfect person
yeah I know
well you're and we're showing you right
there with McConaughey right there on
the sidelines which one's better looking
you know what right there I'll go toss
up right there I'm not gonna throw a
challenge flag on it like that that's
also right there so uh and it was
particularly moving even though it was
my first time going there Jay was
telling me you got to come to this one
in particular because it's a Memorial
Day right right before Memorial Day yeah
the thing that struck me that I really
wanted to bring to the audience of this
show was how difficult a weekend and how
difficult a day Memorial Day is for so
many veterans and I'd love for you to
give voice to why that is yeah you know
it's for whatever reason and I think
that's a that's a that's a human
condition
you know when certain dates come around
it can be really hard so a lot of a lot
of these these people that had come in a
lot of these veterans that come in
they've got those specific dates they
remember or you know a tragedy occurred
and they lost somebody or a group of
people and and it can be different dates
throughout the year but then once again
on Memorial Day they all sort of come to
it come to a head you know and you and
you remember all of those men and women
and survival skill survival guilt is a
big issue it's a problem in the in the
community and you know we're always
taught to be deflective and you know be
very very humble in a lot of ways and
not sort of want to talk about the good
stuff that we did
and we were a part of stuff that we're
proud of sure um so we fixate on the sad
stuff and the hard stuff and then when
we have a day like Memorial Day but
we're supposed to remember these people
we were never really coached to
celebrate them you know what I mean and
to remember them in this positive light
and kind of live for them and spend that
day in that time honoring them a lot of
times you know we'll we'll get stuck in
this rut of of missing them and feeling
like you know I wonder if I wonder what
if I could have done something different
we could have done something different
they should be here I shouldn't be here
all these negative thoughts that just
they don't serve us and any and it can
be really difficult and and talk about
that isolation like a lot of people a
lot of veterans will isolate on days
like that and you know we see the the
public out there they have a day off
from work and they're enjoying
themselves and we don't understand that
because we're like this is not a happy
day right where it absolutely it should
be you know in a lot of ways and and
then there's that that that conversation
we were having a Wednesday night about
the whole thank you for your service
debate yeah I mean because I towards the
end I guess the if you will civilians
that were in the room spoke up right and
of which I was one because you know I
have never served right and so I asked
the room you know hey I have I'm
fortunate to work as I say in the toy
department apartment yeah here's what I
told somebody about that yesterday it's
a great line I work in the toy
department huh where where I talk about
games and losses and people that say
something is an outrage it's because of
a blown call and the NFC Championship
game at any rate so I said hey was win
uncle Chris I said to the room I'm like
hey and I know you your dad is in the
Coast Guard correct yes and you you went
from military base to military base when
I was right so I say to the room what
should I say to people when I'm on my
show Friday say before the the weekend
of all these sports and the Indy 500s
Monday etc
what do I say that people should know
what do you want me to tell people and
one of the folks in our circle raised
his hand and said tell them not to thank
us for our service and that blew me away
I'm like why and and J 2 and J Jay yeah
Jay was just like what are you talking
about what are you talking about cuz
most people will see somebody like
yourself Nate again Green Beret Special
Forces you said you spent most of your
time as Special Forces right right yeah
and yeah I mean on a day where you're
alive yeah I want to tell you you know
thank you for doing what you've done but
that is not particularly helpful is that
the way I don't ever want people to
think that because there are some people
that that are offended by those words
even on Memorial Day veterans and I
think that's not healthy you know
because it's coming from a good place
most people that say those things mean
those things you know what I mean yes of
course there's gonna be some people to
just maybe say something out of
obligation or you know feel like this is
what I'm supposed to do or something
that you want to hear right right right
give you something that you'd like to
hear right because sure I think most
people just like most people are good
people motor most people that say that
they really mean it's coming from a good
place
so I don't you know I don't want us to
as a as the veteran community I don't
want us to you know become offended with
that or or you know or say don't say
that to me on Memorial Day this is not
that's not what it's about you know it's
not about thanking me for my service
about those that they don't hear anymore
but I don't want that you know but it is
important for the public to understand
that it's a very difficult day for us
and it's not about us that are still
here you know it's about those that paid
the ultimate sacrifice and I think
everybody knows that you know so on that
day and we talked about different things
that could be said there's a million
things and there's no perfect answer
there's no perfect expression or gesture
there's no perfect protest when it comes
to protest as you well know you know but
but you know just important to you know
to maybe M
sighs if you're having a conversation
with someone you're gonna reach out to
someone that you know today I understand
it's it's a hard day for you and you
know I want you to know that I'm
thinking of you and and those that you
lost
you know I'm remembering them but I do I
do appreciate what you do you know and I
am you know you can thank someone for
their service but I think it's important
to the caveat that just so they know
that you understand what today is really
about and that's the most important the
so on Memorial Day or throughout this
weekend if you do come across somebody
who has served or is serving you should
essentially say I'm thinking of you
today and those that you lost right yeah
yeah and contention just leave it at
that because again the thing that really
hit me hard was how difficult it is and
how singularly focused many of those men
and women in that room were about a
sense of dread yeah
that Memorial Day was coming right yeah
what are they going to do what will they
do with themselves what can they do to
remember those that they have lost
and if amongst all of those thoughts
clanking around the temples somebody
comes up says thank you for your service
it can really just hit them right in the
gut and that really that really hit me
hard yeah and I wanted to have a
conversation with you Nate Boyer about
this today
ya know it's so true I mean that that
anticipation of the day eats people
eats a lot of these people up you know a
lot of these guys up and I I think I was
so fortunate when I got done that I went
right into football and I had another
focus and something to sort of you know
get me through that stuff and another
team again you know so I didn't really
even kind of transition out of the
uniform until I came out here until
after football was over um and then once
again I was fortunate to have you know
people like Jay in my life that that
wanted to make sure that my next step I
was doing
than for those communities that I served
right or that I was a part of and but
then to meet so many of that like Denver
and AJ who you've had on the show you
know who they run our la chapter
I mean Denver you know in particular in
his in his unit and to seven in the
Marine Corps they lost a lot of guys a
lot on back-to-back deployments you know
in Oh 8 no 9 which is now 10 years ago
and when he got out he didn't have
something like this and a lot of those
guys in his unit did the same thing as
he did they didn't want to talk about it
they didn't want to ever think about it
again and those dates and particularly
the Memorial Day was just this
anticipatory dread you know every every
year of just like it's coming it's
coming
people aren't gonna understand I'm just
gonna be alone I'd rather be alone today
you know and then they go into this this
isolation thing and it's just yeah it's
cyclical and it's hard to get out of and
and nobody's blaming the the you know
people that don't understand that and
don't know I mean but it's just like you
said it's it's just education you know
like anything out sure I'm helping
people understand and I was just helping
people understand about you know how to
communicate from one person to another
from somebody to somebody who served but
let's let's talk a little bit Nate Boyer
again here on the Rich Eisen show about
what folks who are watching and
listening to us who have served that
they can do to get out of this
Riptide to not succumb for the lack of a
better phrase right to this sense of
dread here emerging vets and players org
is a site that you can go to other
places that you can potentially go to
what what what advice would you give
there right now there are so many
organizations out there veterans
organizations and you know that
essentially you need to you need to
still be part of a tribe in some way you
know what I mean and you need as a
service member that's connected to us
forever we are people of service whether
you joined because it was court-ordered
or whatever your reason once you put
that uniform on you became a person of
service and that's how you're gonna be
forever and if you don't have that in
your life in some way
you're gonna feel empty you know and if
you're aware that or not like that's
what a lot of that is I know that's for
me because everything that's instilled
in us is what can I do for the man on my
left and right it's it's net typically
about you it's about the team but
specifically the others you know the
ones around you and if we don't have
that mindset and a little part of that
in our daily life it's really hard and
that's what's great about a group like
MVP is we get in that room and we train
together and then when we we sit around
and chat it's all about building each
other up you can work on your body and
then you work on your mugs and your
spirit all at the same time I saw that
with my own two eyes it really is
powerful yeah yes I mean it's it's it's
just it's crucial that's just a part
that like emotional release is something
that we have to have the Spartans way
back when they had a sort of a grieving
period after a battle where they would
like they were encouraged to mourn you
know in some way and sort of let that
that out you know and it doesn't always
have to be in the form of tears but you
got a you got a share you got to be
vulnerable in it and you know whether
it's in sports they say you know what do
you are you hurt or are you injured and
the military is suck it up and drive on
and it serves a purpose in battle
understandably but then now that it's
over like you can't you can't live like
that anymore you know what I mean you
got to be able to and willing to to let
that stuff off your chest and and and
share it and what better place but with
a group of individuals who have a shared
experience and understand you know where
you're coming from yeah and again the
website is vets and players org at
merging vets and players on Twitter and
there's a spot here in Los Angeles right
there's one in Chicago did you open one
in Atlanta as well yet Los Angeles Las
Vegas Chicago in Atlanta and soon to be
New York City that's great yeah so
that's great so people could just seek
out and and communicate and be in a
group as you say to find themselves in a
tribe exactly and get stuff off there
Chad mean it was so important to see
people just on
themselves with in a friendly
environment yeah give each other crap I
mean it's just like when we were yeah
whether it's sports locker room or a
team room in the military like there's
some heavy stuff we talked about but
I'll say you know you've got a you've
got to have that light side to you've
got to be able to yeah to laugh a little
bit yeah laughter the tears and in terms
of Memorial Day right here in Los
Angeles because we are on throughout the
Southern California area and especially
on angels radio AM 8:30 if you want to
join Denver and AJ that's right they're
taking a walk from the Santa Monica Pier
to the Los Angeles National Cemetery on
Memorial Day they're gathering at 6:30
in the morning
so nice bright bright and early ed up
get up and and join them bring an
American flag a friend a family member
and some water because he's gonna take a
walk and it's a nice walk but you wind
up into the Los Angeles National
Cemetery and pay respects yeah there's a
ceremony that they do there every year
so they'll be there in time for that
it's really cool and what's the workout
that you you all were talking about the
the Murph yes yeah the Murph challenge
Michael Murphy and tenet Michael Murphy
was he was you know teammate with marcus
luttrell and a lone survival story that
many people are familiar with Pete Berg
movie exactly yeah
lieutenant Murphy to make a radio call
basically to call in support put himself
in an exposed area knowing that he was
going to be probably killed and he was
but he did it for the man on his left
and right as we talked about but his
favorite workout was this this
ballbuster of a workout and you know he
was a PT stud and so every year on
Memorial Day millions of people across
the country it was sort of really
popularized through the CrossFit culture
do a workout in honor of him and it's
you know you run a mile and then you do
100 pull-ups 200 push-ups 300 squats
with a weighted vest on and then you run
another mile yeah we're watch this
Shawne Merriman and Chris Pratt yeah a
bunch of that we wanted in
and you doing it in in the unbreakable
gym here yeah we did it we did it this
week or last week I guess in honor of
Memorial Day today yeah Chris is a big
supporter of the veteran community
there's Randy Couture and obviously
Glaser and that was it was cool but it
sucks you know we just want everyone to
get a little taste of like you know man
not everybody's cut out to be a seal I
guess huh
Nate Boyer 37 that's your twitter handle
and also Instagram handle before I let
you go the Waterboys org as well you're
you're tight with long you do a lot for
that organization now now that he's
retired I guess he's gonna throw himself
fully into this he's already fully
manned I guess it's a wrongfully for the
poor no you know he climbs there after
this back-to-back Super Bowls that he
went to weeks later he's on the top of
Mount Kilimanjaro with these you know
wounded veterans and former NFL players
and yeah raising money for clean water
wells in Tanzania he's awesome he's on
yeah I was saying I mean what a year
he's having right I mean Walter Payton
Man of the Year his Virginia Cavaliers
win the C double-a tournament after last
year where they were the yeah it was the
lowest of the lows and now he walks away
from the game healthy man father to do a
lot of great stuff I have a feeling
capable human being yeah right back at
you to nape or 92 wow thanks for coming
on here thanks for coming on here and go
to vets and players org at merging vets
and players and I'm thinking of your
comrades that you've lost thank you very
much sir that's all we ask
and everyone should on Memorial Day take
it take a moment to remember those who
are no longer with us because they
fought for our freedom to have a day
like Memorial Day Off and enjoying our
families thanks for being here heyget
take a moment moment but but but do
enjoy yourself do you enjoy yourself
just understand we know why we get to
that's all Nate Boyer here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel
39 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app